Jenna Bush Hager gets emotional talking
about the Matt Lauer scandal while megyn
kelly invites his accusers on her show
it was hard not to be here yesterday
it's hard to be here today the 59 year
old newsman released a statement on
Thursday following his termination from
NBC amid allegations of sexual
harassment as I am writing this I
realized the depth of the damage and
disappointment I have left behind at
home and at NBC repairing the damage
will take a lot of time and
soul-searching and I'm committed to
beginning that effort it is now my
full-time job now Kelly is encouraging
the women who have come forward to tell
their story on her show megyn kelly
today as hard as it is to report on one
of our own colleagues we remain
committed to telling people's stories if
they choose to come forward it and on
the final hour of today Hoda Kotb reread
Lauer statement and Hagar her guest
co-host got emotional when I started
here I remember somebody saying NBC the
donatio is a family yeah and that feels
cliched that feels like something people
just say but that's true yes and so when
something rocks your family uh-huh it
rocks all of us it rocks the people that
you see right here and it rocks
everybody behind the cameras who we love
and that includes a man who was a mentor
to many of us
[Music]
you